-Quand on retrouve aujourd’hui,
par exemple
on a retrouvé en Scandinavie, dans une tombe
viking, une petite statuette de Bouddha,
ce qu’on ne sait pas, c’est combien de temps
a mis cette statuette pour arriver jusque-là.
De même on a trouvé des pièces romaines
dans des fouilles archéologiques au Japon.
La question est: ont-elles mis un siècle,
deux siècles ou trois siècles ?
Et ça, évidemment, on ne peut pas le savoir.
Donc la mondialisation, certes,
on a tendance à la voir du côté européen,
ce qu’elle est en partie,
mais elle n’est pas que européenne.
Au XVIIe ou XVIIIe siècle, il y a toujours
des incertitudes qui sont très fortes,
sur le devenir des bateaux.
Si on prend par exemple
le commerce triangulaire,
un voyage "circuiteux",
c’est-à-dire pour faire le triangle complet:
on part de Nantes et on y revient
après l'Afrique et l'Amérique,
ça pouvait prendre un an et demi.
Donc pendant ce temps-là, on pouvait avoir
des nouvelles de son investissement,
mais tant que le navire n’était pas rentré
il y avait toujours une crainte de perte.
Il y avait des coefficients d’incertitude
qui pouvaient être assez importants.
À Nantes, et dans les villes portuaires,
on a cette présence du monde
qui est affiché sous les yeux des individus.
Celle-là, c’est la plus belle.
-C’est quoi le nom de la rue?
-C’est la rue Kervégan ici.
On a l’Europe qui est ici.
On a l’Afrique, qui est ici.
Et à nouveau ici, donc deux mascarons
avec des têtes d’Africains.
On a l’Amérique qui est ici.
Et on a l’Asie qui est ici.
Ça répond à ce que les gens
attendent de voir.
Quand vous représentez quelqu’un,
comme aujourd’hui
à l'étranger on peut représenter
un Français avec une baguette et un béret,
peu importe que les Français se baladent
avec une baguette et un béret ou pas,
mais quand on voit une baguette et un béret,
ça répond aux attentes.
Si vous voulez montrer un Français,
mais que ça ne lui ressemble pas,
alors tout votre
effet de communication s’effondre.
-Entre l’exemple du Bouddha de la tombe
viking d’Helgö en Suède, datée du IXe siècle,
et le commerce triangulaire
des marchands nantais au XVIIIe siècle,
vous avez compris que la mondialisation
n’est pas propre à notre époque.
Je rentre de Nantes,
et avec le CRHIA qui est un laboratoire
des Universités de Nantes et La Rochelle,
spécialisé dans l’histoire internationale
et atlantique,
on a eu envie de faire une vidéo
sur l’histoire de la mondialisation.
On en entend beaucoup parler
en ce moment avec la Covid,
et tout le monde a compris
que l’accélération des échanges
avait aussi accéléré
la circulation du virus.
Mais c’est un processus
dont on a du mal à retracer l’origine.
-Certains vont même jusqu’à dire
que finalement,
à partir du moment
où les êtres humains existent,
ils entrent en contact avec les autres,
et donc à partir de là si on voulait pousser
à l’extrême le raisonnement,
le phénomène de mondialisation
serait presque inhérent à la nature humaine.
-Partant de là, on a voulu remonter
aux sources du phénomène,
grâce à quatre chercheurs spécialistes de
périodes allant du Moyen Âge aux années 2000,
on va revenir sur les grands moments et les
différents aspects de cette mondialisation.
Annick Peters-Custot,
spécialiste de la période médiévale,
nous parle de la réapparition au XIIe siècle
d’une forme de mondialisation
qui existait déjà à l’époque romaine.
-Il y a un vrai tournant au XIIe siècle,
qui réactive complètement,
en même temps que le commerce d’ailleurs,
par le biais du pèlerinage,
les circulations en méditerranée.
Cela dépasse très largement
le cadre méditerranéen,
car les populations viennent d'Angleterre ou
du Nord de l'Europe, voire de la Scandinavie.
Donc on a une réactivation en réalité,
d’une mondialisation qui était la norme
au moment de l’Empire romain,
et qui est dans un cadre politique
très différent et beaucoup plus fragmenté,
qui est réactivée à la fois par le commerce,
et par le pèlerinage.
Et donc, sur ces routes de pèlerinage,
passent également quantité d’aventuriers,
de commerçants, etc.
Ce sont des canaux de transmission
qui sont pluriels,
avec des individus qui ont plusieurs
motivations lorsqu’ils se déplacent.
La connexion entre la Chine et l’Occident,
franchement elle a toujours existé.
On a trouvé dans des tombes scandinaves
du Xe siècle un petit Bouddha,
une cuillère éthiopienne,
des pièces de monnaie islamiques.
L’énorme Empire mongol du XIIIe siècle
a tellement favorisé
les circuits commerciaux que l’Occident,
qui se croit le maître du monde,
vit sous le rythme d’un poumon commercial
qui est déjà la Chine au XIIIe siècle.
Et que l’expansion
de la Grande Peste s’est faite
en raison
de cette mondialisation commerciale
promue par l’unification
de l’Empire mongol.
Disons que la notion impériale
s’orientalise peut-être un peu,
mais la première puissance économique
et commerciale, c’est l’Empire islamique.
Il y a l’Empire byzantin qui est connecté
à l’Empire perse
et connecté à l’Empire chinois,
et ensuite il y aura l’Empire moghol.
Donc ces grandes
constructions transnationales,
certes comme nous avons une vision
européo-centrée, occidentalo-centrée,
on dit qu'il n'y a plus d’empire
en Occident.
C’est faux, il y a eu
l’Empire carolingien et ottonien,
mais les dimensions
ne sont pas les mêmes.
Mais surtout, les grands empires
il y en a toujours.
Mais ils ne sont pas forcément
sur les zones
qui sont celles de l’Occident
et donc,
à partir de ce moment-là, même si l’Occident
se perçoit comme le centre du monde,
il est en fait satellisé.
C’est une puissance secondaire
pendant une large partie du Moyen Âge.
Et quand, à partir du XIIe siècle,
ces courants commerciaux se récréent,
il y a d’autres formes impériales.
L’Empire vénitien est un empire.
C’est un empire commercial.
Il a besoin en fait, puisqu’il n’a pas
d’hinterland dans sa lagune,
Venise a besoin d’un empire commercial,
en guise de zone d’approvisionnement.
Il va pousser vers l’Est en fait.
Il n’y a plus l’Empire romain au sens
de ce grand et vaste espace unifié
par des infrastructures monétaires,
commerciales et politiques uniques,
mais il y a des empires bien plus grands,
beaucoup plus riches,
beaucoup plus importants
et pas moins bien gouvernés,
que sont les Empires islamiques,
perses, chinois, mongols.
Et puis les empires commerciaux,
qui prennent le relais
comme structure portante
d’une mondialisation internationale.
Mais comme l’Occident est un peu à côté,
on fait comme si ça n’existait pas.
C’est juste que le centre de gravité
a basculé à l’Est.
-Eric Schnakenbourg,
spécialiste des contacts atlantiques,
nous explique que l’expansion européenne
à l’époque moderne,
est déjà motivée
par les désirs des consommateurs.
-Le monde atlantique a cette particularité
de mettre en rapport trois continents:
l’Europe, l’Afrique et l’Amérique.
Et donc l’idée, c’est d’éclairer un pan
de la mondialisation de l’époque moderne.
Il y a aussi l’Asie bien sûr,
qu’il ne faut pas oublier.
Mais c’est vraiment une interaction
très forte entre les trois continents
puisqu’il y a une interdépendance
qui se met en place.
Les hommes sont fournis
par l’Afrique avec les esclaves.
La terre et les ressources,
en quelque sorte, de l’Amérique.
Et les capitaux, et finalement
les consommateurs, par l’Europe.
Donc il y a un rapport étroit
entre les trois continents
On ne peut pas comprendre l’histoire de l’un,
sans tenir compte de celle des deux autres.
On est vraiment dans une histoire
que l’on appelle "interconnectée".
Ça renvoie à une question:
est-ce qu’il y a une mondialisation,
avec des modalités différentes ;
ou des mondialisations?
Ça c’est vraiment un débat
entre les historiens.
À titre personnel, mais peut-être
car je suis historien moderniste,
j’ai tendance à croire qu’il y a un grand
phénomène de mondialisation avec des phases.
Des phases d’accélération, des phases
de recul, des spécificités particulières.
Mais si on regarde bien,
dès le XVIe, XVIIe, XVIIIe siècle,
les informations, les hommes,
les techniques, les savoirs circulent.
Ça circule dans le monde atlantique,
entre l’Asie et l’Europe.
Évidemment,
ça circule plus lentement qu’aujourd’hui,
mais ça circule.
Et les réflexes sont les mêmes,
par rapport aux importations de produits
étrangers qui sont parfois dénoncés,
car ça fait sortir des richesses
ou qu’on se pose
des questions sur ces produits:
est-ce que le café ou le thé
sont bons pour la santé?
Il y a aussi les diffusions de modes,
comme le sucre.
C'est un produit de demi-luxe
au XVe siècle,
qui devient courant au XVIIIe siècle.
Par exemple, on a des études très sérieuses
de médecins sur le tabac,
sur les bénéfices de la consommation
de tabac pour la santé.
Par exemple, on croyait que le halo de fumée
du tabac protégeait des épidémies.
En période d'épidémie, les gens se mettaient
à fumer pour se protéger.
Il y a eu des études médicales
sur la consommation de café, de thé.
On se pose vraiment des questions.
Pourquoi les Européens se lancent dans
ce qu’on appelle "les grandes découvertes"?
Parce qu’ils ont besoin de produits
qu’ils n’ont pas chez eux.
C’est ça qui est fondamental.
Les Chinois se contentent
de ce qu’ils ont chez eux,
et dans leur environnement immédiat.
Il n’y a aucune raison pour les Chinois,
de chercher à aller en Europe.
Ils n’ont besoin de rien en Europe.
Mais les Européens ont besoin d’épices,
ils ont besoin de sucre,
besoin de thé, de café, etc.
Donc ils vont là où on produit ce café.
Les Chinois n’ont besoin de rien.
Il n’y a pas de raisons qu’ils lancent de
grandes expéditions à l’autre bout du monde.
Et finalement, si on veut
renverser la perspective jusqu’au bout,
le moteur de la mondialisation européenne,
ce sont les carences de l’Europe.
Ça n’est pas sa supériorité,
mais ce sont ses carences.
On travaille un peu plus,
parce qu’on veut acquérir un peu plus.
Ce qui est, au sens propre, le luxe.
Le luxe, c’est ce qui n’est pas nécessaire
mais qu’on va s’acheter
parce que ça nous fait plaisir.
Ça c’est un moteur fondamental.
Et qu’on réfléchisse bien, aujourd’hui
c’est encore bien souvent le cas
de nos existences et du travail qu’on fait.
Nos besoins primaires,
une fois qu’ils sont satisfaits,
c’est ce qui nous fait plaisir.
Ça peut aussi en grande partie venir de loin.
Soit directement, soit indirectement.
-Antonio de Almeida Mendes travaille
sur l'histoire coloniale ibérique.
Il nous rappelle que la mondialisation
est aussi une affaire d'imaginaire,
de décloisonnement de la pensée.
-Le mot "esclave" n'a pas
la même valeur aujourd'hui
qu'il a pu avoir
dans les sociétés d'Ancien Régime.
Aujourd'hui, l'esclavage,
c'est cette notion
de propriété
que l'on peut avoir sur quelqu'un.
C'est donc quelque chose qui fait partie
d'une atteinte aux droits de l'Homme.
Dans les sociétés
sur lesquelles je travaille,
les esclaves acceptaient totalement
qu'ils étaient esclaves
puisqu'ils faisaient partie
d'un cadre normatif
où ils étaient
dans des relations de dépendance.
Être esclave
faisait partie de ces sociétés
où l'on ne pensait pas en termes de liberté.
Plein de gens vivaient
chez d'autres gens.
Il y avait donc des rapports d'allégeance,
des rapports de domesticité.
Aujourd'hui on englobe tout ça
sous le terme "esclavage",
alors que, dans ces sociétés-là,
tout était bien codifié.
Je crois que tout l'enjeu
de l'historien, quand on travaille
sur plusieurs mondes,
c'est d'essayer de dire :
"Tout n'est pas pareil partout."
Et il faut quand même avoir
cette volonté d'englober le monde,
sinon on fait une petite
histoire nationale, de chez soi,
sans sortir de son cadre national
et on produit un discours
qui est tout aussi rabougri.
Il me semble donc qu'il faut aller
vers des échelles mondiales et globales.
Mais ces échelles
ne doivent pas être uniformisantes.
Évitons le discours universaliste disant :
"C'est pareil partout dans le monde".
Chaque société a son propre imaginaire
qui décide ce qui est acceptable ou pas.
Cette histoire de 1492,
on peut donc la raconter
comme l'histoire des découvertes,
ou des navigateurs : Vasco de Gama,
Henri le Navigateur, Christophe Colomb...
Ça, c'est l'histoire classique
qui se déroule avec un fil
qui part de A et qui arrive à B
à la fin de la colonisation.
Elle peut aussi se raconter
avec ce nouveau monde, les Caraïbes,
que veulent créer les Européens.
Christophe Colomb arrive
en octobre 1492 aux Bahamas.
Dans son voyage de retour,
il écrit une lettre à son protecteur
en mars 1493 dans laquelle il dit :
"J'ai découvert le paradis.
"De ce paradis, on va pouvoir
régénérer le monde."
D'abord, on découvre, puis on se rend compte
qu'ils sont anthropophages.
On leur propose de devenir chrétiens car
il y a quand même ce discours sur le salut.
Ils le refusent parce qu'en face,
bien sûr, des gens résistent.
Ici, il faut replacer l'histoire
à un niveau d'homme,
qui est de savoir si les Indiens
doivent être esclaves à vie
ou est-ce qu'ils ont cette capacité
de devenir libres
et de devenir nos égaux
malgré leurs différences.
Donc Las Casas dit : "Vous voyez,
quand on leur propose de devenir chrétiens,
"ils deviennent de bons chrétiens,
ils réfléchissent par eux-mêmes.
"Ce sont des êtres humains,
dotés de raison."
Et Sepúlveda dit : "Mais non,
vous voyez, ce sont des animaux.
"Ils sont comme des perroquets
qui répètent le Notre Père,
"mais ils ne peuvent pas
réfléchir par eux-mêmes,
"parce qu'ils portent en
eux une forme d'animalité
"qui les pousse à être anthropophages,
"qui les pousse à la nudité.
"Ils ne pourront donc jamais
"intégrer le monde civilisé,
parce qu'ils sont nés animaux."
Il faut donc qu'ils restent
des esclaves à vie
parce que leur nature est celle-là.
On ne peut plus juste faire
une histoire des grands hommes.
Par exemple, où sont les femmes
dans cette histoire ?
Où sont les minorités ?
Donc là aussi, il faut se dire
que la documentation qu'on utilisait avant,
qui était plutôt officielle et qui nous
permettait d'écrire l'histoire de Louis XIV,
elle comportait autant de mensonges
et de contre-vérités qu'une histoire
qui repose sur des sources fragmentaires.
J'ai par exemple écrit
un article sur le Congo.
Comment le roi du Congo
est devenu chrétien,
et pas comment les Portugais
ont christianisé les Africains.
Ça change tout de se dire
qu'il y a des acteurs de l'autre côté
qui prennent l'initiative et que, pour eux,
devenir chrétien impliquait d'autres choses
que ce que pouvaient s'imaginer
les Européens en arrivant sur place.
Ça nous permet donc,
à partir d'un évènement connu,
une date qui fait partie de l'histoire
disons occidentale ou universelle,
de repenser l'autre côté.
Ceux qui ne sont pas dans ces documents
et dans ces archives officielles d'habitude.
-Michel Catala, spécialiste des relations
internationales en Europe au XXe siècle,
évoque l'accélération de la mondialisation
et les oppositions qu'elle a suscitées
depuis une vingtaine d'années.
-On s'en aperçoit d'abord dans l'économie,
dans les années 80 :
puisque ce sont d'abord les
économistes qui le disent,
avec la libéralisation
des échanges, etc.
Puis on s'en aperçoit
avec la chute du mur de Berlin
et notamment dans les années 90,
à tous les niveaux.
Que ce soit au niveau des échanges culturels,
des migrations, des échanges humains,
cette accélération, cette intensification
des échanges de toute nature
entre les êtres humains,
par-delà les frontières,
c'est ça la mondialisation.
Et c'est vrai qu'elle s'accélère
considérablement à partir des années 90.
À partir de ces années-là, le concept même
de mondialisation est débattu.
Il fait partie du débat public.
Dans ce cadre-là,
il provoque aussi certaines résistances.
On peut noter des résistances
de groupes plus ou moins organisés
un peu partout dans le monde
– beaucoup en Europe, mais aussi
aux Amériques et en Afrique –
et ces groupes se retrouvent
dans la dénonciation d'une mondialisation
qu'ils jugent comme étant le symbole
d'une dérive
trop libérale, trop capitaliste,
d'une sorte de libéralisation
débridée des échanges
qui auraient des conséquences
sociales et politiques
qu'ils condamnent.
C'est donc cela
que l'on va appeler l'altermondialisme
à partir du milieu des années 90
et qui va véritablement
être au cœur de l'actualité
entre 1999 et 2004.
En France, par exemple,
c'est le mouvement Attac,
c'est José Bové, tous ces mouvements
qui se cristallisent à ce moment-là
et qui font réseau d'ailleurs.
C'est assez intéressant parce qu'ils font
réseau dans le monde entier
avec plus ou moins de réussite,
mais ils se mondialisent eux-mêmes,
si j'ose dire,
puisqu'ils se constituent
en réseaux internationaux.
On en parle beaucoup dans ces années-là,
notamment à cause des grandes
manifestations anti-mondialisation
qui, d'ailleurs, tournent généralement
en affrontements extrêmement violents.
C'est notamment le cas à Seattle
pour le sommet de l'O.M.C. en 1999.
Ça continue ensuite
jusqu'au milieu des années 2000,
jusqu'à ce que le mouvement
s'essouffle un peu.
C'est un mouvement qui correspond
en fait assez bien à la mondialisation,
puisqu'il n'est pas vraiment organisé.
Ce sont des réseaux
plus ou moins informels,
un peu partout dans le monde,
avec des manifestations un peu partout
et qui, en plus, est aussi
une des premières formes
d'un mouvement social mondialisé,
en quelque sorte.
Il proteste contre la mondialisation,
mais d'un autre côté,
prospère également
grâce aux grands éléments
qui facilitent
la mondialisation contemporaine.
Par exemple, on les trouve très présents
en Europe du Sud, en France ou en Italie.
On les trouve également
très présents en Amérique latine,
à travers le mouvement
de défense des paysans,
de l'acquisition de nouvelles terres
par les paysans, etc.
On les trouve aussi un peu
en Amérique du Nord, en Inde ou en Afrique.
Ce sont des mouvements mondialisés,
mais qui sont enracinés sur des territoires.
C'est plutôt une cristallisation
de mouvements existants
qui se reconnaissent dans cette critique
de la mondialisation
qui est d'ailleurs vue exclusivement
comme une mondialisation économique libérale.
C'est-à-dire que c'est vraiment centré
contre cette mondialisation-là.
Ils n'ont pas de vue globale,
comme un historien ou un scientifique,
de l'ensemble de ce qu'est
la mondialisation,
ni d'ailleurs de son ancienneté
ou de son aspect historique.
Eux, ils sont vraiment cristallisés
contre une dérive
qu'ils appellent la dérive ultralibérale,
depuis les années 80,
les années Reagan-Thatcher,
et qui va se développer d'une manière
trop forte à leurs yeux dans les années 90.
Par définition,
la mondialisation d'aujourd'hui,
avec les nouvelles techniques
de communication,
peuvent nous permettre de découvrir,
en l'espace de quelques heures,
un tube coréen, un manga japonais,
un film iranien
ou des blogueuses
ou des youtubeuses du monde entier.
Ça participe aussi à l'édification
d'éléments culturels communs.
Il ne faut pas être naïf non plus :
les états existent toujours,
les frontières également,
certains états veulent contrôler
tous ces phénomènes
et ce que l'on pouvait penser,
dans les années 90-2000,
comme un triomphe d'une mondialisation
dans laquelle les états
se retrouveraient marginalisés
et n'auraient plus
le contrôle des choses,
on en revient et on se rend compte
que ça n'est pas si simple.
-Très bien, merci.
-Je ne sais pas comment vous allez
vous en sortir avec tout ça mais...
-Je fais mon montage, ne vous inquiétez pas !
-Ah, vous faites du montage !